voilà dans le lin des restos du coeur
parisien nous allons retrouver agnès
poirier véronique colucci
est ce que vous êtes ce que vous
m'entendez comment comment se présente
cette opération solidarité cette année
vous êtes on a presque envie de dire
vous êtes rodé maintenant oui bien sûr
rodez non je dirai jamais on dit on peut
être efficace ça c'est sûr on peut pas
être rodés au fait de côtoyer la grande
misère parce que c'est ça qu'on voit
donc on a beaucoup d'entrain on est des
milliers de bénévoles c'est vrai mais
c'est encore chaque année un pari
insensé qu'on essaye de tenir compte
on essaye de faire que les gens qu'on
rencontre soit le moins possible dans la
misère et qu'on puisse les aider oui
c'est sûr
quand je vous disais rodez s'est érodée
du point de vue du point de vue de
l'organisation
j'ai autre question est est ce que
comment évolue la population qui vient
dans les restos du coeur comment est-ce
que ça se passe bon on a vu que c'est
toujours très très difficile d'aller
demander est ce qu'aujourd'hui dans
cette population qui vient dans les
restos du coeur il y à des changements
est ce que les contacts sont encore plus
facile que les années précédentes
il faut vous dire que cette année donc
c'est l'ouverture de la cinquième
campagne
c'est vrai que les gens nous connaissent
de mieux en mieux maintenant que très
souvent bénévoles se sont d'anciens
bénéficiaires qui se porte à nous aider
puisqu'ils ont vu comment ça pouvait eux
les aider et que on essaye non seulement
à travers les restos du coeur mais ce
qu'on a créé cette année qui se fait le
relais du coeur qui prend fonction à
partir du mois de mars quand s'arrête la
distribution alimentaire à travers ses
relais on essaye de fournir une aide
plus comment dire
plus efficace encore que la distribution
alimentaire seul c'est à dire que si des
gens ont des problèmes à remplir leurs
dossiers de rmi s'ils ont des problèmes
juridiques médicaux et que nous on
puisse pas les aider je vous entend plus
on peut en tout cas s'approchait
d'associations amies qui elles le feront
comment fonctionne la solidarité est ce
que ce que vous diriez qu'elle est de
plus en plus présente et les deux elle
est de plus en plus forte
écoutez si c'est à travers les
restaurants du coeur c'est sûr que la
solidarité est gigantesque puisque
regarder les pouvoirs publics sont là
les médias vous êtes là toujours les
artistes plus que jamais gg preuve à la
main de cette tournée des [ __ ] qui
est un très beau disque maintenant on a
également et c'est le plus important
peut-être des milliers de bénévoles est
toujours toujours les donateurs grâce à
qui on fonctionne je dois dire que une
aide substantielle de la cee puisqu'elle
représente plus de la moitié de notre
budget
nous permet aussi de sanctionner encore
et on peut remercier le président de
l'or mais on est connue chine une
dernière question s'il y avait un manque
a souligné aujourd'hui dans votre
organisation et dans cette cinquième
année de solidarité qu'elle serait ce
manque
vous allez comprendre on distribue 275
mille repas par jour et on n'a même pas
4 % de frais généraux c'est vous dire
que c'est quelque chose qui est je crois
assez efficace malgré tout il on évalue
à travers les chiffres du revenu minimum
d'insertion à un million de personnes
celles qui sont dans le besoin alors
vous voyez que la différence est grande
et si on voulait faire
idéalement on est loin du compte donc on
a toujours besoin et de dons et de
bénévoles et de tout ce qu'il faut pour
faire fonctionner l'association des
chiffres qui parlent véronique colucci
je vous remercie
[Musique]